if you haven't read
um Chateau artiste I think you can still
find copies of his book online on Amazon
it's basically a collection of all his
blogs
um he's like kind of one of the ogs
probably before you know the Rolos and
the ruches of the world and you'll see a
lot like if you go to his older like
archive sites and his blogs or his book
you see a lot of this stuff like still
talked about today
um this again there's really not a lot
of new ideas in the space when it comes
to
um you know dealing with these matters
but
the Skittles man is a very good one it's
right up there with the 16 Commandments
of poon and I have a video on the 16
Commandments of poon you guys just
search for it on my site you'll find me
break it down but that was a fun one too
anyway the Skittles man
let me read it uh reader Fabian linked a
funny story on don't date him girl blog
and in quotations uh he had several lady
friends who stayed the night at his
house and he claimed they were just
friends he frequently forgot important
details about me such as the fact that I
had a sister my birthday and what sort
of hobbies I had he blew me off
constantly would return calls a week
later with the excuse of I was busy I
often spoiled him with gifts rides and
sex to receive a bag of Skittles in
return and I don't even like Skittles
that was the only gift I ever received
from him I met new friends and they were
bonding over worst ex-boyfriend's story
and suddenly we realized boy a lot of
these sound like the same what was his
name it was the same guy this dude was
dating every chick out there he was a
skittles man so these so these gals were
talking about him so this is so the
title of this uh blog is be a skittles
man
the second part to that is in an
unintentional juxtaposition for the ages
this reader Joel or you know by the name
of Joel left a comment
on my pimp slap post is the title of it
about a wedding that he attended so this
is another version of another guy I just
attended a wedding the bill for which
paid mostly by the parents of the
ride but was initial input from the
group
groom's parents not at any costs today
like they're they're pretty expensive
150 000 would probably be like just an
average one
um but yeah
would easily sorry would easily pay for
the private education of several
children so
educations you
modest it could have paid for a modest
but nice house in a good neighborhood
and in many parts of the country uh he
said the flowers cost at least fifteen
thousand dollars of this wedding it is
amazing what the matriarch does the
darwinian purpose of this I believe is
to keep the husbands working their asses
off to keep them broke so they can't go
out and buy younger women sorry buy a
younger women for their next wife or
keep a concubine really there's no other
logical explanation for this excess
spent two men it goes on and says two
vastly different experiences with women
one man gets all the girls he wants for
The Bargain Basement price of a bag of
Skittles while the other man marries a
woman in a wedding ceremony featuring
flowers that cost fifteen thousand
dollars
how much you want to bet the first guy's
rotation of girlfriends is hotter than
the second guy's fifteen thousand dollar
flower wife
how much you want to bet the first guy
gets all the I'm not gonna say what's in
the blog here because we're trying to
keep it clean for YouTube but let's just
say all the fun time stuff that girls do
in the bedroom
he desires while the second guy will be
begging for his once a month starfish
sex as soon as the vows are exchanged
and dried up
if one of these guys sorry if one of
these guys is a herb who's more likely
to be and I think you guys know the
answer to that is our friend at the
wedding with a fifteen thousand dollar
flower arrangements
fact odds are good that you will enjoy a
bounty of women and love if you act like
the Skittles guy fact odds are good that
you will spend the rest of your life
begging for tepid sex from the same old
boring gal if you act like the fifteen
thousand dollar wedding flower guy
be a skittles man don't be a fifteen
thousand dollar wedding flower man
I've been in the company of a lot of
women who hailed from all sorts of
stations in life I know the sound of a
woman in love and it usually sounds like
the woman in the skittle story bitching
and moaning about a world-class [__]
chasing him from here to Kingdom sorry
from here to Kingdom Come to cajole him
to surrender at least a small measure of
his autonomy which he never does and
always always goes back to him after
they have a bad fight I've been that guy
he says
I've also been around all kinds of women
from the wedding flower story they
usually sound like they are more in love
with the idea of fifteen thousand dollar
wedding flowers than they are with their
man now anybody I'm just going to pause
for a second on the on the blog here
anybody that's been married to one of
these in-demand gals these high
maintenance gals will resonate with what
I just said there you will spend more
time with her discussing whether or not
the invitations have to have a purple
diamond on it or a pink diamond on it or
we can go with the combination of the
purple pink and yellow in the trifecta
color or we can do this upgrade and get
the heart-shaped diamonds they will
spend more time on that [__] not banging
than the Skittles man is running around
passing out a bag of Skittles from time
to time anyway carrying on they never
chase and their men are in the
permanently disabling position of
constantly bending over backwards to
satisfy their women's whims women who
are princess princessified
it's a funny way to put it princessified
have power over their men and even over
the kinds of men who themselves have
power over the other men
the women know this and they
subconsciously resent it
Joel is right the matriarchy and all of
its silly silly manifestations
extravagant weddings Diamond Nookie bar
pop culture propaganda daddy government
disease is structured a handicut man to
cut them off at the knees fitting really
because a man on his knees is exactly
where he'd have to be to agree to a
fifteen thousand dollar wedding flower
arrangement
the finances aren't the core issue it's
the corrosive effects such as wasteful
expenditure for a woman will have on her
attitude the matriarchy lows the fee
lows and fears the Skittles man the
freeloader who nonetheless basts in the
love of many women the matriarchy would
rather men be like the wedding flower
man slaving dutifully as a nameless
faceless Cog in the machine paying his
dues for two pence of a [__] society's
Little Helper
at the end of the day what's it for to
thanklessly pump out a cannon fodder for
the wars of the future
F that sideways the rule book was
written to constrain free thinkers like
you
when you know the score when you
understand that this is life that sorry
that this life is all there is and there
never will be your legacy in gold or
works or kids means nothing when your
Consciousness is obliterated into
nothing and your deathbed is lined with
a Garland of regret and Pleasures denied
and the memory of your Decades of
pointless sacrifice crawl slowly across
the walls like night Shadows to
suffocate you in your final Doom
amazing writing I actually you know it's
funny because there's because there's
passages in the book that just suck it's
just one of the most poorly written
books in some areas but but some of
these like blogs have been updated
somebody's fixed them anyway
it's almost done uh only then will you
look at your Blushing Bride in the eye
and inform her that there will be no
fifteen thousand dollar wedding flowers
and she can hit the bricks if that's
unacceptable to her better yet tell her
there'll be no wedding and no marriage
she can love you without needing the
permission of the state
that's a great test for women if you can
tell a woman I don't have any interest
in inviting the state into my life but I
love you and I like doing things with
you and I don't want you to go anywhere
and she stays that's a good check that's
a green flag if she's all about I have
to have the party I need to have the uh
the trifecta Diamond Arrangement on the
invitations we need 700 people at our
wedding blah blah blah for that night
kick rocks you know look especially if
you've got kids out of the way and
you're an older guy like what's the
point it's it's utterly pointless right
anyway
some newcomers are against agass that's
an interesting word I've never a cast
when they read my stuff I'm gonna have
to Google that one afterwards they think
this blog must be a joke or the ravings
of a lunatic a Madman driven to the
brink by a particularly damaging
experience with the next always who hurt
you right
no while I've had my Joys and sorrows
and loves and heartbreaks just like any
other man possessing a wealth of
experience with women on the whole most
of the women in my life have been and
continue to be cherished loves my lunacy
is a clear-eyed vision of Neo after the
Matrix revealed after the Nate The
Matrix is revealed to it reality makes
lunatics out of all of us but only those
with the eyes to see and the ego to
spare ever embrace it unconditionally
such a beautifully written article I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full-length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out